yes my name is jr. and I want to be the
next big thing in street way so I'm here
today to meet a real live street wear
designer I see if I come up with my own
hot noodle inspired fashion collection
in just three days
when did you get started in fashion it
was a passion it was something that I
wanted to do what advice would you give
me as my mentor my sensei you need
something that people can instantly
recognize as your brand this streetwear
collection is going to need branding
marketing how are you gonna get your
word out there and giving a beautiful
look you can do this three days this is
what noodles fashion HQ this is ground
zero where all starts and plus things
first I need a brand and either
collection something with an on trend
let's do this two words Eastern Europe
so hot right now
[Music]
welcome to pot noodles ss-19 Slovak
inspire streetwear for the design a
noodle lover that's it
the protest will be here by tomorrow
it's just 19 baby ok looking oh my
goodness the winter collection yes
mostly this is the Lord's Day put the
wrong date 2017 today my main goal to
get the word out about my new brand
hopefully people like it real good day
hi hello this - ah stars oh I see
looking at high-profile stuff because
something that rises late well Donald I
can the mission is out there so just
about tomorrow again I look but fun
fingers crossed all right so we're
London today trying to do a new lookbook
these are my mates done Barry and Gary
paints a flush there do you boys
[Music]
little flavor to rap I've done the
lookbook I'm going to our mentor my
sensei bender designer to show him a new
lookbook so fingers crossed likes it jr.
I've seen all the artwork that you've
submitted earlier designs how do you
feel like you went like it was really
long
how do you guide it I think that what
you've accomplished in just three days
is really impressive streetwear
collection
[Music]
and I think that it should be really
proud of yourself where did you get
those models just a couple guys I know
really well done friend I just want to
thank pop noodle for this massive
opportunity they're giving me I managed
to make a fashion collection in just
three days so it just goes to show if
you save a little time each day
anything's possible
and also keep it in to the street
because it's more common soon I'm out
[Music]